There's a sense of pride and the flip side of that a huge sense of humiliation that comes with this illness
Because it's called mental illness is not called brain illness. I call it cancer of the soul.
It eats away. It's very subtle. It's
very, like I said, insidious.
It is something that has a hold on you. So you're not willing, no one is willing to really talk about it.
If you are diagnosed with cancer and you're losing your hair, you have to talk about it. There's lots of sympathy that goes with that.
There's not a lot of sympathy that goes with depression.
It's a very private illness.
There's such a misunderstanding, a lack of understanding, about what this illness really involves.
The single biggest misconception about depression is that it's just a lack of will power.
It's that if you're tough and in control of yourself that you can overcome it.
That's not true.
Depression is an illness. It is a physical
problem with your brain it's not a matter of willpower
anymore than cancer
or heart disease is a matter of willpower.
It is still widely believed that
you can power through depression, you really can't.